hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play
Slenderman the original all right you
guys gave me some advice I don't know if
this I think this might have started me
over yeah I did and yes God we all know
it's the minecraft sound good okay open
it all the way please please all the way
thank you
oh yeah we're starting over I don't
wanna be room door open all the way
please thank you come on come on I said
maybe I go okay I didn't get a good look
at him before that sounds good thank you
for that keep watching you loop now ah
there it is and I don't look at that or
else Italy's gonna break my keyboard
and that's what you guys meant about the
opposite door unlocking there we go dead
oh man okay and there's a compass that
you guys were talking about - I got a
compass now now the tape go csgo flip
just shove it in with the other one go
to the red okay all right anyway that's
what you guys were talking about about
the red thingy anyway that's not the
back somewhere and I think oh good god
good okay now I just need to go in the
direction that this is pointing me right
right
okay maybe I don't know I'm just gonna
head towards this where it's pointing me
and not do that because that makes my
head hurt and I'm just gonna keep going
until like ah here it is oh this looks
lovely oh yeah this is good okay
shut up crow we're getting crow shut up
crow what are you doing what are you
doing how do i how do I do this how do I
get in
Wow its gate crank oh okay crank that
gate oh yeah
crank it good oh yeah oh that's dumb
no no there's a crow with the key he's
got a key
I gotta find a key give me give me the
cane get it okay
get back here you [ __ ] freakin [ __ ]
[ __ ] crow yeah yeah you heard me I'm
such a badass person like that okay what
do I do
he doesn't seem to be getting any closer
I just need to like chase into a wall
come here crow I need your key I need
okay
oh gosh stupid crow I hate you so much
you're gonna hit it what fence
eventually I'm gonna get I'm out no mo
get you now a markiplier demon in the
night now markiplier jeez you really
would a fellow the hell let's go I know
you dropped it oh there it is key got it
now what do I do with it oh this must
unlock a door in the house got it okay I
got it I still got it okay oh I seem to
be wobbling back and far oh okay there's
a sweet light and I'm close if not right
next to it I am NOT right next I passed
it
all right so this company sees now
pointing me in the right direction
yay-yay got the key now what it is key
open there's more of those little
douchebags in here okay not that
definitely ah perfect a gun hell yeah
come get some plenty well with that a
handy gun damn right oh it's so handy ah
ah ah yeah kill ya know I can't seem to
pick up this to tape is there any way to
drop but I got like a rock party like a
rock oh there we go that's right right
click tape alone all right pop
Slendy popped a cap in his yes yeah
showed him okay what do we got here do
you want to be alone hell's to the yeah
I feel like that's a that's a trick
question isn't it okay go get the gun
I'm going to get the gun I'm gonna get
the gun before they can get me and I'm
gonna shoot them in their friggin face
oh yeah
Oh picked it up and it got full ammo
again so I'm just gonna go where the
compass tells me I'll shoot anybody in
the face I see you yo yo I didn't work I
didn't send that did not seem to work
I'm just gonna go no I need to kill him
ah he came right at me
y'all saw okay oh this guy outside I
need to kill them all
[Music]
coming of your running now markiplier is
a demon in the night yeah they're gone
now finally I won yeah I did it thank
you for the help guys you really were a
big help to me I like that I mean I know
that was made for like a I think like a
24 hour or something contest or
something like that uh no no who's made
very quickly but it was exceptionally
atmospheric it had a good bit of content
to it I mean the lows right it's
graphics for something but you know as
opposed to anything else it still held
the atmosphere so I say that's a winning
that's category and I definitely can see
and I know a lot of you have been
telling me to watch the Marble Hornets
stuff but oddly enough I looked back I
checked that out recently and I realized
I've already watched those like a long
time ago I watched I want to as soon as
I saw the first one where the guy was
Slendy was standing on the back porch I
was like oh I've watched these and so
yeah not all of them cuz they've been
coming out with new ones but I watched a
lot of them when they first came out so
anyway that's all that there is for that
there'll be more slender stuff as it
comes out but the Slenderman shadow Maps
has um have for now I think stopped
because I don't know any the Creator
like took a break or something or he's
got that special project in the works
set he's gonna let you guys are anyone
know about soon so when that comes out
expect something from me obviously I'll
be playing it but for now I think that
most of the Slender stuff is slowed
until slender arrival comes out until
the other slender game that I can
remember comes out and this special
project that mark Steen has so anyway
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotations for more videos that
I've done and as always I will see you
in the next video bye-bye